s
pour la plupart, mais certains
ont largement passé l'âge de se
retrouver dans une maternité.
La vingtaine de nourrissons
n'a que ce sous-sol et ces
infirmières dévouées pour
veiller sur eux et les protéger
d'une guerre qui a fait fuir
la majorité des résidents
de ce quartier de Kiev
où ils se cachent.
LUDMILA YASHENKO, infirmière
- Nous entendons les explosions,
n n n nous n'avons pas le temps
d'avoir peur. Ces petits anges
nous appellent. Il y a peut-être
des explosions, mais ici,
il faut courir changer des
couches, préparer des biberons ;
les bébés ne nous donnent pas
le temps d'avoir peur.
- Par-deouououout, dit Ludmila,
les nouveau-nés ont besoin
d'amour.
- Bien sûr, chacune d'entre nous
aimerait être avec sa famille
pour partager notr
commun, notre catastrophe,
mais nos familles comprennent
très bien qu'on a besoin de nous
ici parce que ces enfants
ont besoin de soins spéciaux,
ils sont ipapapapaparents
alors, ils ont particulièrement
besoin d'amour.
- Tous ces enfants sont nés de
mères porteuses. Leurs parents
sont en Europe, en Chine,
en Australie et au Canada.
Depuis une vingtaine d'années,
l'Ukraine nununununue une
destination de choix pour
la gestation pour autrui.
Avec la fermeture progressive
de la Thaïlande et de l'Inde en.
Environ 2000 bébés naissent
de mères porteuses chaque année
en Ukraine. Elles seraient
rémunérées jusqu'à 20 000 $
américains pour leurs services.
NONONONONONOGA
médecin en chef, BioTexCom
- Dans les premiers jours de la
guerre, la première semaine,
c'était trèilililililile de
retenir les gens. La panique
est très dangereuse.
Des parents biologiques ont
fafafafafafaire venir leur mère
porteuse de l'étranger pour
qu'elles accouchent là-bas.
Mais il faut comprendre que dans
la plupart des pays européens,
la gestation pour
interdite et c'est considéré
comme trafic humain.
- Mais ce ne sont pas les seuls
problèmes légaux auxquels
doivent faire face les familles.
Les services d'État civil ne
forererererereresque plus et
selon la loi en vigueur, les
familles doivent être présentes
en Ukraine pour confirmer
la nationalité de l'enfant.
Or, avec la guerre, beaucoup de
parents n'arrivent pas à faire
le voyage pour venir chercherles
prennent encore le risque, dit
Igor Pechenoga, le directeur
médical qui fait aujourd'hui
double emploi en servant
dans la réserve militaire.
- Quand les parents arriventà Ks
d'alerte partout, mais ils
prennent leur bébé dans leurs
bras avec les larmes aux yeux.
Ils sont passés par toutes les
difficultés. Ils n'ont pas pu
avoir d'enfants pendant 20 ans,
et enfin, ils en ont un.
Un enfant, c'est la plus grande
joie que vous pouvez avoir
dans une vie.
- D'autres familles ont recour
à des O.N.G. pour faire évacuer
l'enfant qu'ils attendent.
BRYAN STERN, cofondateur
Project Dynamo
- Salut tout le monde, c'est
Bryan, nous voilà en route pour
Jérémie 3. C'est le bébé Harry,
un citoyen canadien,
notrdidididididididien.
- Le voici, Harry, huit jours,
emmitouflé dans des vêtements
chauds par Ludmila juste avant
son départ. Cette organisation
américaine a fait la route
jusqu'à Kiev pour ensuitee e e a
frontière de la Pologne
où il a pu rencontrer ses
parents canadiens pour
la première fois.
D'autres missions d'évacuation
sont en cours de préparation
pour d'autres familles au
Canada. Project Dynamo affirme
avoir reçu tout le soutien
nécessaire de l'ambassade
canadienne maintenant
relocalisée en Pologne.
La mère porteuse du petit Harry,
on ne la voit pas ici. En fait,
on ne voit aucune de ces mères
dans la maternité improvisée
de Kiev.
Cette seule entreprise, l'une
des plus importantes en Ukraine,
affirme que près de 500 femmesps
parents étrangers à l'heure
actuelle. 500 femmes pour qui
le choix de fuir leur pays
en guerre n'en est pas un.
Ici Marie-Ève Bédard,